I'm Clint Kelly i work at whidbey data
I'm gonna go without the microphone if
you have any problems hearing me just
let me know I could pick up the mic it's
no problem today I'm going to talk to
you about TG patrick gave a nice
introduction to TG in his kickoff for
today it's an open source platform for
building real time big data applications
and we recently added support in key G
for Cassandra as a baggy case so first a
little bit of motivation let's say that
you want to build a big data application
put a couple of canonical examples up
here on the slide maybe you're working
at a retailer for example an online
retailer and you've collected a lot of
data over the last several years about
your customers what they've all the
goods that they purchased what they
clicked on what they've looked at and so
on and you want to enhance your site
such that you take all of this data you
probably run it through crew who do for
spark or something like that do some
machine learning on it and training
algorithm baby calculate item item
similarity something like that and then
you want to take these trained machine
learning models and you want to use them
in conjunction with with some context
for the way in which your user is
interacting with your site right now if
you're building a retailer for example
you might want to look at all of the
items that someone has in his or her
shopping cart everything they've looked
at in the last 10 minutes on your site
and use that to recommend some some new
stuff that they want to might want to
buy in real time so how do you go about
building this well right now there are a
lot of open pretty awesome open source
technologies out there again talked
about some of these earlier obviously
Cassandra which we're all here to learn
about
and then other data storage layers like
like HBase there are some great
computational frameworks out there like
Hadoop group also spark and then tons of
stuff built on top of these different
frameworks hi for example or pig for
querying data new dsls they're even more
abstract on top of MapReduce things like
scalding from Twitter even stuff like
Impala there's all kinds of stuff out
there but to to get from that to
building one of these applications is
pretty non-trivial there's a lot of
plumbing you need to use to connect all
of these different all these different
open-source platforms together and
there's a lot of additional
functionality that you need to build and
it's not simple and so with that in mind
we developed over the last several years
kiji and the idea behind kiji is that
it's a platform that can help you you
can use as a bridge to get from all
these different open-source technologies
to your final big data application
whether it's online retail and
recommendations other kinds of analytics
and so on and make yourself happy so a
little history of kiji it's developed at
we be data were the small start-up in
San Francisco originally founded by some
folks from google and Cloudera who
worked on solving these kinds of
problems in the past and want to produce
a more general framework that would
enable others to benefit from what
they've been around the lessons that
they've learned one thing that's
interesting is that we originally built
kiji exclusively on top of HBase and I'm
going to discuss the kiji data model a
little bit later and it might be a lot
of it would be really familiar to anyone
who's used Cassandra but there are also
a few things that might look a little
funny and those are mostly because it's
built on top of HBase and as Patrick
mentioned there's been a lot of customer
interest in using kiji from customers
who are currently using cassandra and so
this year we've worked on adding
supporting PG for Cassandra so again one
thing to keep in mind that I think is
interesting in this talk is that rather
than building an application from
scratch that would run out Cassandra or
taking an application that we originally
built for HBase and lay reporting it to
work on Cassandra instead we're building
a single framework originally for HBase
that now provides a single single data
model on a single API on top of two
different you know sequel databases a
quick overview of the talk I'm going to
begin by describing about three slides
the kiji project all the different
components of kiji and how these make it
easier for you to give to build one of
these big data applications then I'll go
over the EEG data model some of the high
points of it and then talk about how we
map the kiji data model on to Cassandra
what some of the challenges are current
status at the project next steps and how
you can try it so first the kiji project
I usually think of the components of
kiji as falling into into three main
categories first there are some
components that we use for real-time
scoring I had trouble figuring out how
to visualize real-time scoring I don't
know this is the the best I could figure
so there are things for doing real-time
scoring some batch machine learning
other things offline and then the data
storage layer which interacts with HBase
and with Cassandra the real-time
components again are used for doing
scoring on your website taking some
website or whatever your application is
taking some some data that's changing
really really quickly again like what
people have clicked on in the last five
minutes what's a user shopping cart and
so on and applying that to a train
machine learning model and using that to
give some some feedback to your
application now we have a lot of
sophisticated systems for managing
different train machine learning models
a lot of the time in application like
this you'll have multiple different
models that you're working on wants
run some some a/b testing or different
kinds of experiments so we have a pretty
good system for uploading models to your
website deploying them taking them in
and out of production and so on there's
also a rest server that you can use that
your application can use to interact
with Eugene on the batch side we have a
nice really expressive design specific
language that you can use to describe
MapReduce computations it's based on on
Twitter from scalding which is really
nice it's similar to similar to the API
you get from spark or sunny sparker
slumming bird if anyone's used those
Scala based it looks like you're
interacting with the collections library
in Scala we also have a machine learning
library full of whatever you need for
building your big data application item
item collaborative filtering things like
that and then hooks for talking to all
of your favorite you know tools that
your data scientists might want to use
things like I've soon adding support for
our also then finally there's the data
layer we call this key G schema and this
is what I'm going to talk about most
today so this provides key G schema this
money when I started working on adding
support to key G for Cassandra we found
it in especially in cql Cassandra had a
lot of the things that we'd added takuji
schema to make HBase easier to use one
so I've left you know left all that out
of this talk but a couple of other neat
things we add we have one as we use Avro
for really for complex records this is
similar to the the user-defined types
that Patrick talked about this morning
so you have complex records with name
fields nested lists and maps and so on
and we also provide again a reasonably
sophisticated system for managing
different schemas so if you're building
one of these applications over time you
might want to add some fields to your
records take away some fields the date
you might change something that was
a flow to a double or wasn't him too
long or something like that so kiji
schema provides a mechanism for letting
your schema evolve registering different
readers and writers and making sure that
everything's going to be able to read to
or read from and write to the database
without any issues and again signed up
excuse me something to keep in mind is
that it was it was a rose a bill for a
page age base and now I've added support
to us for Cassandra and again as Patrick
alluded to earlier in production now
which is is pretty exciting there's one
fortune 500 retailer that's serving live
recommendations online with key G and
also hope our abode recently when my
public uses key to prologue energy data
that's a great example of the time
series data the Patrick talked about and
uses it for doing some analysis
generating reports so that covers a
quick overview of key G and now I'll get
into the the data model the data models
pretty straightforward as you'd expect
all the data exists in a collection of
tables those collection excuse me those
tables are composed of rows and every
row has a row key and some data in key G
we call the roki on entity ID and the
nati we support composite na IDs so you
can have multiple fields from a data
model that you use to index a row and
some of these are hashed some of them
are on hashed as again as Patrick was
explaining before like the hash
components you can use to make sure that
you distribute data you can li among all
the nodes the nodes in your Cassandra
cluster the region's in your your HBase
installation and the unhatched
components you can use to enforce some
kind of ordering in the rows in your
database in case you need to do some
some scans over a certain range of data
so here let's say that we're building
some kind of
application maybe let's take an example
let's say we're building something
similar to like Spotify or Rdio or
Pandora or building a music application
this is one of the kind of canonical no
sequel data data modeling motivators
you'll see as you read more and more
documentation and go to more talks and
so on so the data within our row we
organized into column families again
very similar to what we do in Cassandra
and at age base and so let's say for our
music application we have some
structured data for every user this
would be things like the user's email
address maybe it's payment information
mailing address maybe a little avatar
for the website and so on and then we
have some time series data perhaps the
all the songs that the user is listened
to since he started using our
application within every column family
we have naturally distinct columns I
refer to the column names within the
column families as qualifiers so in this
case here we've got the email the
payment information for our user Bob and
let's say that Bob is on kind of a
Beatles binge right now he's been
listening to a lot of a lot of Beatles
music so we've chosen in this data model
we've chosen to name every column with
with the song with the excuse me name
every column with the name of the song
that Bob's listen to so here where our
data model differs a little bit from
when you get in Cassandra and where you
can kind of see the roots in HBase is
that every column can also have multiple
time-stamped versions so whereas
Cassandra this is something that you can
you can add to your your data model as
Patrick demonstrated a few minutes ago
in TG we have built-in support for this
kind of time series date
and then within every version of a
column again you can have a complex
complex record we use we use a pro
formas so that kind of covers the that
covers really quickly the logical
organization of data and key G again you
have rows that have column families then
every column family of columns columns
can have different timestamp versions
and we use avro to give comp to assign
complex data types or to the different
columns so now let's look at how data is
organized physically and one of the
goals in developing ki g + keygen schema
was allow you to kind of think of the
logical organization in the physical
organization of your data separately so
let's take the and this is similar
against what Patrick just spoke about or
you want to arrange you want to arrange
your data physically such as it maps
really well to the different kind of
queries in application like this we
might have a couple different query
patterns let's say that we have some
data that where maybe all the songs
you've listened to in the last hour or
in the last day and those might be the
ones that we want to look at for serving
real time serving recommendations in
real time maybe we want to look at all
the songs everybody's listen to in the
last day that's that you know might
indicate what kind of mood you're in and
we want to serve recommendations I want
to recommend to you songs that are
similar to the ones you've been
listening to right now and then on the
other hand we might also want to keep
track of all the music you've listened
to the last year the last two years and
then use that for some batch machine
learning jobs that we might run run
every day or so what to do so just take
the data model I just demonstrated may
be divided it up into a couple other
column families 14 songs you listen to
in the last the last day 14 last year
you know we still have the structured
information so the structure information
probably only need one version of this
column access speed might not be a big
an issue the big issue as long as they
listen to you today if we're using these
for real time scoring this kind of data
we want access to really quickly you
might want to cash it and it also
expires really quickly so we'll probably
set a TTL 24 hours for all of this data
and then the data for for machine
learning access not such an issue but
we're going to keep it forever so in key
G we can we have a notion of hoops
screwed up my graphic sorry about that
we have a notion of locality groups so
you can group one or more column
families into a locality group and these
locality groups have common properties
like the time to live for the data
whether the data is cached or not
whether you're using compression a lot
of these options are similar to what
you'd get in a table and cql so in our
case here we might separate these three
different you can put more than one
column family into a locality group on
this example I've just chosen one to one
mapping but you can we could put these
three column families in two different
locality groups and then set some
options for whether we want it to be
compressed cached and so on and one
thing that's important to note here is
that even though we put these column
families into locality groups everywhere
in your application logic when you
reference data you only use the name of
the column family and the qualifier you
never reference the locality group so if
you want to move columns between
locality groups for example that doesn't
doesn't change any of the other code in
your application
so quick overview of key G schema again
it's similar to what you'd get in
Cassandra and HBase and naturally
therefore also the big table was
originally based on the data model for
HBase that's why we get these this
explicit support for different timestamp
versions of the same column when you try
to separate the logical and physical
organization of data and I also have
support for for complex data types and
in evolvable schemas ok so now and talk
about how we take this this data model
from key G and map it to Cassandra the
first place we'll start is with the
locality groups as I mentioned these
have these kind of control how your
organizing data on disk if you're you
know if you have data for one particular
query you or one query pattern you
probably want to have it all co-located
on disk so we chose to map these
locality groups to tables and as I go
through how we map the kiji data model
the Cassandra up here on the bottom I
have the cql for building a Cassandra
version of a kiji table just to kind of
illustrate while I'm talking about a
little bit more so for every locality
group we're going to we're going to
build a separate table then the entity
IDs map to the primary key in Cassandra
so within Cassandra if you have a within
your primary key you kind of kind of two
types of columns you have partitioning
columns which go through your murder 3
or md5 hash and determine what replica
note host that data and then there are
also clustering columns which don't get
hashed and which you can use the control
the ordering of data within a wide row
so the hashed components of our energy
yet excuse me the hash components of our
entity ID we map to the partitioning
columns in Cassandra and the unhatched
components will be map to clustering
columns
next the family of the column family the
column qualifier and the timestamp all
these other components that you use to
identify one unique instance of a cell
in kiji we also mapped the clustering
columns and one thing to point out here
where we're sorting all the data again
has Patrick demonstrate in his talk and
again we're sorting by everything's in
ascending order except for the time
stamp or version as we call it which is
sorting in descending order so again if
you want to get the most recent version
of a cell you can just use the women
wanted it's available right away and the
column values because we're using a bro
to serialize these complex records these
just map two blobs out here just to kind
of give you a flavor for how this works
if you have this data in a cassandra
table you can query it and c ql and you
see that you get one unique row in c ql
for each unique data value in key G
which is what you'd expect the forge
related values of the cells are kind of
a garbled mess because they're all
serialized we have some some ideas on
how to alleviate that pain and again
just to recap this shows how the data
and one of these key G tables
implementing Cassandra will be organized
on disk so again it's sorted first by
the the partitioning columns in your in
your cassandra table and then by all
those different clustering columns so
the parts of the entity ID that are
unhatched than the column family the
family the column qualifier and the
timestamp and again as patrick said if
you want to have efficient queries you
want to make sure that you've designed
this data models such that you're doing
continuous scans and not not jumping
around everywhere so let's look at how
you now map a aquarium ki g two
aquariums
Sandra table and one thing I should note
here is that key G is a lot more
permissive in the kind of queries that
you can do than Cassandra even though
you so when we're designing a kiji table
we want to put everything that we need
for for a single query in one locality
group but we still allow people to do
queries across locality groups and in
the HBase implementation of key G in
fact you can do all kinds of different
compared and set operations and so on
the paths that cross different locality
groups so let's can get some get a
little hairy so let's look at again our
example of our little music application
here and let's say that we we just want
to look at all the information in Bob's
info column family yo maybe he's editing
his account information something like
that want to serve that on a website or
excuse me on a web page and this is a
pretty straightforward query we're just
getting the data from a single column
family so we just have to specify all
the elements for the partition key and
er sorry for the partition columns and
the clustering columns up until we get
to the qualifier version and we'll get
all the right data back actually there
is a bug in this slide you don't need to
limit one here because in our in the
definition i showed earlier for the
locality group we set the max versions
to one anyway so we don't store the most
recent version here but anyway this is a
pretty straightforward translation of
this query no problem one-to-one between
kiji and Cassandra now where this gets
interesting is if you have to support a
query that it crosses column fam /
crosses locality groups and therefore
crosses your table or c ql tables so
let's say that you know maybe Bob's
emailing his buddies with some
information about the last time he was
the one of these songs or he's posting
on Twitter or something like that and we
need to get some information from
the info column family as well as some
in some of the structured data from the
last time there's some of the complex
data for the last time you listen to the
song song help so here this gets a
little tricky but it's pretty
straightforward to implement we just
have to do two separate queries one to
each of the cassandra tables it
represents a locality group in TG so
this you know there's no problem works
pretty well and again one thing that's
kind of neat because we're fetching just
the most recent time that Bob listen to
help and because of the way we ordered
all of our queries we gave you just use
the limit line and get the most recent
value back so now let's say we want to
do a query and it's more like what we
might one for some kind of batch machine
learning process want to get a lot of
the information or all been to all the
songs that Bob is listen to for a given
period of time so instead of getting you
know looking at just one song like
getting the most recent version of the
time you listen to help now we want to
look at all of the all the listen events
for him in a given day range so this
looks like a pretty straightforward
translation again to to Cassandra it
looked that you know it's similar to
what we did on the previous slide but
here we use instead of having women one
we just specify a time stamp range
unfortunately this doesn't work in c ql
there are some restrictions that are
there to prevent you from doing kind of
asinine queries like this if you look
back to how the the data is organized on
disk if you do a query like this you
know you're going to be doing all
skipping through tons and tons of data
cassandra is really going to have to go
through all of the data you have here
for this entire songs column family and
then just skip everything that's outside
of this tank time range and it's
potentially really expensive and I one
thing I'd also mentioned since you need
to talk about data modeling this would
be a horrible do model if you ever want
to do it very like this but in key G is
something that we allow
users to do even if it doesn't work out
so great that's something you can do
things like this in HBase also but this
blows up in Cassandra's so we have to
work around this I'm kiji and a lot of
the work in providing support for
Cassandra in key G has been identifying
corner cases like this and in figuring
out workarounds so what do we do about
these kinds of tricky queries I showed
earlier that well a lot of time you can
just filter in c ql you can use
inequalities on some of the different
clustering columns and that works most
of the time and it's usually a sign of a
well designed usually if you've designed
your schema appropriately for the access
patterns for your database this will be
sufficient sometimes for queries that
cross locality groups even sometimes for
those that don't we can break up one of
these key G queries into multiple cql
queries the the fallback plan which is
pretty ugly but does work as long as you
have enough memory on your machine it's
just the fetch all the data you could
possibly need and then do filtering on
the on the client so as an example in
this query we could just fetch all the
music listening history kerr bob over
the whole time he's use our application
which hopefully is a significant amount
of data if business is successful and
and then just filter it on the client
but that's that's pretty pretty terrible
and the bottom line is that designing a
table layout is pretty important so
really we have to work with the kiji
users and educate them about the best
way to design scheme and such that they
match their query that one other thing i
want to to mention is that we used in
the implementation of key G schema we
used the Java driver and the native
protocol exclusively and the this Java
driver has really really nice a sync API
that lets you you know use futures and
blast out a lot of queries before you in
a lot of queries in parallel before you
get any data back and so that helps a
lot with
performance of breaking these key G
queries up into multiple Cassandra
queries one other thing just want to
note while we're discussing how reported
key g2 to work with Cassandra we had to
rewrite some new new input and output
format classes for Hadoop again this is
mainly because one key gquery that you
might want to use in a MapReduce job can
generate multiple Cassandra queries so
we have a new MapReduce format it also
works with lube too and again we use the
Java driver instead of the thrift API
and using this these input and output
formats you can combine the data from
multiple Cassandra queries into one data
structure that you get in your ear
mappers but so the status of the
projects we have an initial release
coming in two weeks this is like a
somewhat of an alpha release I went
through a lot of the different
components of key G earlier and this
initial release will include support for
TG scheming for running MapReduce jobs
but it's not yet been fully tested with
the rest of the entire kiji ecosystem
over the next quarter we're going to
work first on adding support for
Cassandra and all of the other
components of key G all the batches of
real time and so on and also work on
exposing some of the kind of neat things
you can do it Cassandra to key G users
I've already done this in in HBase we
want to kind of choose to do the same
thing in Cassandra so that you could use
the programmable consistency levels for
example maybe on some time maybe
sometimes you want to do you want to use
one for the consistency level for your
rights maybe sometimes quorum and so on
and finally we've we've looked at better
ways to integrate TG with cassandra such
good if you're using a non-key g tool to
look at data at a Cassandra database it
looks natural and right now the the
biggest place where we fall short with
that
is the value of the data on your tables
since those are all stored as blobs we
have a command-line interface for key G
that DC realizes these blobs and renders
the most text when you're looking at it
but it would be pretty straight forward
to maybe the fork the cql shell and do
that d serialization there so you could
inspect the data in your tables that way
we've also looked at just when I read
and write to and from DG tables taking
our a bro date and actually mapping it
to the user-defined types or coming out
in Cassandra 2001 so one thing I want to
mention is that you know thanks to
everybody in the Cassandra community
it's been we only got started on this
project a couple of months ago and
everyone the user lists been really
helpful there are a lot of awesome
videos out there most of the webinars
the meetups and so on or the heat
Cassandra summit are all online that was
a big help and the free training from
datastax and so on made it really easy
to get up to speed so finally if you
don't want to wait two weeks you can go
to key G org and download our
development kit this is a tarball really
just have to untie ur to run one excuse
me run one commands and you'll be up and
running with a full loop and HBase
cluster at about two weeks we're going
to add support that will also improve
Cassandra and there are a lot of
tutorials online for learning to work
with all the different components and
learning how to build a big data
application with keychain and also if
you're you know if you're interested in
working on this we are hiring um okay Oh
perfect so anybody have any any
questions yeah
I know so the barracks are showing
before those map directly to each base
or we have a separate system oh no sorry
that's the yeah yeah
so why do we choose
oh so well Cassandra is really a
compliment to do and we were originally
working with HBase and there's this
customer demand for Cassandra a lot of
people in this in the space we're going
after at we be data are using Cassandra
and asks us to add support for it
anybody else yes sir kasama who is
already losing job pays on the back in
g yeah to migrate so it should be
pretty easy to migrate you could just
write a you know a MapReduce job to dump
out all the data in your HBase EG table
and then use a bulk importer to load it
back into the cassandra one and you
should be able to use all the same PG
files that describe the layout of your
table and all the same code to access it
should work without any modification you
have to modify them to have 11 you
shouldn't have to modify anything down
to the exact same layout file oh yeah go
ahead
so we haven't done performance testing
yet that's something that's on the
agenda for the next few months but I'd
expect that we see you know whatever the
normal trade-offs are between HBase so
one of the one of the big differences is
that HBase has support for a lot of
really rich server-side filters so you
can do filters in HBase that let you
filter the data coming back by like a
regular expression on the column
qualifier for the column family even the
value in all kinds of different version
version of filters and so on so that was
one of the the as i showed earlier we
can kind of replace that with
inequalities in the the cql query but
that's one of the big features that is
kind of missing right now and we're
looking at options for implementing that
in Cassandra there are a couple other
projects out there that do support doing
some operational operation on the server
yeah yes
so the the column families here are in
the in the kiji data model so within
Cassandra those the reigns of those
farming families just map to a single
clustering column in within Cassandra
know so I'm not totally sure what you
mean by column families I know in
previously in Cassandra what was called
a column family is now called a table in
a secret well so and we are using those
and then there's these super column
families and things like that but we
start supporting this a 2 dot 0 dot six
so we're not using frigging that's
correct any type of type anymore okay
all right thanks everybody